you are a terrific jazz musician and i'm
bringing this up for a reason i think
to understand
jeff goldblum which is impossible but to
really understand what makes this man
tick i think is your love of jazz you
are constantly improvising in the moment
and tuned into that crazy galaxy that
real jazz musicians are tuned into
and a good friend of mine just went and
saw you perform the other night and said
that you were fantastic yes very nice
that's very encouraging thank you yeah
we played the disney concert hall yes oh
my god two a couple nights ago
but what i'm saying is am i am i correct
that
that there's something about music
you're
i just feel like you're in tune with
some jazz musical score all the time
yeah is that do you think that's and
this is a compliment by the way thank
you so much i like j well i aspire to it
i'm a humble student of jazz and of the
technology of presence in all its
various ramifications in the podcast
world in the jazz world the musical
world and everything oh i had thought by
the way aren't there has it hasn't
anybody sung songs a snippet of song
about friendship uh as you're still
looking for friends by the way
how many friends do you need you've been
looking for how long have you been
looking for friends now
how many of you found by this time
jeff they don't often take that's the
problem i am um
i don't wear well over time that's one
of the problems yeah but i feel that we
are you know sometimes plants
they have to graft they have to graft
into each other is what you're saying
yes i'm right there with you i think we
have we need to graft into each other
yes we need to very very much yeah but
think of do you know any songs about
friendship well the the song that uh
you know we are going to be friends uh
that uh white stripes did jack white
he's a good friend of mine and that's
the song i wonder
[Music]
he rolls back
with
anyway um
my point is uh that that's a friendship
song and that's that's actually one of
my favorite friendships how's it go does
that have lyrics does the the thing you
fall is here hear the l you sing like a
nightingale i love your voice when you
know when you're not you really like my
voice
when you're not doing that you have a
beautiful authentic conversational
delightful voice can i say something uh
i i'm always so self-conscious that i
put trills and foolishness in there but
you can't i never just sing you just
sang and i loved it yeah
silent night
oh
you're gonna do a thing holy night
all is calm
no it's doing it again right yeah
try to take all the can't do it
no no no
no no no you're just saying so sing that
whatever you want to sing like the other
voice that that's it uh let's see uh
you've got a friend yeah oh no i can't
sing that song how about the jason
isabelle song you sang to us that time
yeah oh yeah um um
oh yeah um how does that go it goes uh
never could be happy in the city at
night that's beautiful yeah um yeah
can't see the stars for the neon lights
beautiful sidewalks dirty and the rivers
worse
underground trains all run in reverse
nobody here can dance like me everybody
claps on the one and the three
am i
the last of my kind
am i
the last of my kind that's very moving
very beautiful
boy you should do you should do a whole
album of songs that way i'd love to hear
you do that he can't do it i can't do it
i just want you know youtuber just
locked an icon i know but can i tell you
something
something jeff i i
i uh i couldn't and i'm supposed to and
i want to write a song with amy mann
right yeah i love it
i adore amy mann and i'm intimidated by
amy mann's talent but um we promised to
write a song together and then the last
thing she said to me i said yeah i'll do
it she said you know it's just got to be
something like sincere
and i met something that you really want
to say and i was like oh yeah oh that's
not going to happen i could do it no i
can't i can't
will you tell them please i was on the
edge of my seat the entire time you were
singing because i thought he was going
to go into some bit and like do
something with your voice things
eventually become a baby it's a bit it's
a you're like joking around well who
knows where it will be
consumed or how it should be presented
but just for your own just for you know
just just do it i'd love to hear just
for me me too and for someone for us i'd
love to hear you do it and you don't
have to jettison your
comedic force of nature you could be
surprising and do one like that and one
like that and one like that but that's a
very useful part of your tool box in my
opinion a very enjoyable one